that's go read my spirit back I shamed
so I look like a baby this game ah I
love it so far I hope you I hope you
brother dig it as well it's it's pretty
[ __ ] interesting not gonna lie ah
where dad hits the sex dungeon all the
ways it's not a gun oh he left us the
camcorder the camcorder has a flashlight
on it it's not really a flashlight but
it should be pretty good test in peace
remember the notes are only added to
your notebook when you can't go to
interface to record events so that it
has a purpose I kind of like that oh hey
how are you doing sir let's the eyebrow
man calm you're dead sir back off Oh Oh
what you gonna do about it huh what you
gonna do about it
and I'm trying to run away like a little
[ __ ] oh yeah see you don't [ __ ] with me
huh that's a very nice forehead sir
well who needs sleep anyway it's not a
battery nope hi if you wanted a brofist
all you have to do with oh never [ __ ]
mind you're ugly hi hi
sad I can sway
you're gonna be a top model one day
Heidi Klum can go [ __ ] herself girl you
is hot you is fabulous yeah that's why I
keep touching yourself this is some
[ __ ] nice porno
this [ __ ] will sell people are into
kinky [ __ ] oh yeah yeah I keep doing
that oh yeah I liked a little shy look
you have all right I'm gonna go to your
friend let's see how he's doing
watch you want to kiss you want to kiss
okay come in come in stupid [ __ ] who's
this it is I maybe father murmurs man
maybe what he looks nervous I would like
to kill him as would I
the preacher asked us not to it would be
implied not here we give him a running
start there's an idea and when we kill
him we kill him slow such patience I
want is tongue
like you've seen a ghost
I sing worse I just saw works look oh
Jesus are you it's sighs it's not they
were waiting for us in this place you
don't Billie under space oh I'm always
here that is [ __ ] up
this games on if they wanna get out
so we can't actually go in their cells
oh dude I don't want to go there
a little shy I'll ask you oh man you
look good you look a real good son okay
yeah I don't know what Oprah tells you
but don't do that okay we're going here
you're asleep well I'm not gonna disturb
a sleeping man okay let's go here a boss
huh oh don't kill me whoa ah ah you did
steak on the piss don't lie to me yo
what the [ __ ] is the matter what do you
care at all what I did I I didn't know
it's sick you're sick but but but I just
wanted to party
please let me party please I see how it
is
oh I see how it is yeah yeah that one's
fun so you guys party with you guys put
it without me
Fabri fight it till the cool part is
I'll never be in a cool kit oh hello
how you doing sir not so good okay we're
back here with the penis guys get you oh
okay cool yeah that went well good job
heads
there we go I don't know why didn't work
this game is amazing so far I'm just
gonna say that wait until I finish but I
say some for you okay while I'm buddies
happy uh god oh oh [ __ ]
God always provides away followed the
blood see this is what my mom always
says except that God always man there's
no more fancy his room it's camping so
this place is pretty cool hello I can't
hear you
follow the blood they said and follow
the blood I shall die
okay right
hello now step down there for that
confidential not anymore
stop I guess we have to hello hello
anyone in here batteries with the -
gardener nananana BAM experiments they
were ritual contra uh-huh tell me mine
tell me mine who plucks your eyebrows
huh yeah didn't think so
alright what do we do here uh-huh okay
well it looks like there's nothing for
us here follow the blood they said oh
wait he was pursuing me well if [ __ ] is
pursuing me
what oh I'm going here hi how you doing
oh I don't be angry it's gonna be okay
did your mama not hug you enough hey
I'll hug you just kidding you're ugly
how do I get past him hey hey hi okay
alright
hey [ __ ] okay okay okay
ha
Oh
what happened
did he go in there crazy [ __ ]
okay so he was in here gotcha
I wonder if you can hide underneath the
bed okay well that didn't really go as
planned in it
follow blood trails jeez all I got this
is stupid elevated that needs to be
activated there was that worse a room in
where that [ __ ] guy was or whatever
let's just take it easy let's take it
easy
one step at a time girl that guy that
guy is cool you're cool we cool we cool
yeah we home hombres yo max swagger how
you you hit me okay just just gonna I'm
just gonna go in here okay just gonna go
in here look at the plant focus on the
plant the plant is your happy place
okay whatever guy just calm down
whatever guy here it has to be something
batteries mnemonics gone to the bane of
Manning I better reload
okay okay just don't want no trouble now
I'll be on my way sir thank you very
much security this thing's like much
god damn it okay we're back here very
disorienting oh there we go there we go
all right ma'am
follow the blood see my mom made this
game I've been telling you bro so many
times my mom was oh not cool not cool
mom
I think the hiding I hate it oh yeah oh
I get it go back in or you may think I'm
in the locker oh that's [ __ ] heart you
piece of [ __ ] duck not cool not cool
[ __ ] ow yo love them yeah yeah oh it
smells like [ __ ] barn okay why can't
I just pick this up and [ __ ] smack
people you know that's what I always
said oh Jesus the gay couple again I
Paragons of patience job like in the
suppression of our desires but no yeah I
don't know what kind of day [ __ ] you
guys are interview but I'm not
interested okay just sign me out please
I'm okay with you guys doing whatever
don't care it what bet but I don't take
no part in it oh god damn it oh god I'm
not gonna jump over there are you crazy
I could die why oh you guys make it
anyway I'm not even gonna go there
okay fine Yolo oh oh well this is
something bad is gonna happen okay
so far so good here we go where did you
follow the blood they said it will be
fine they said okay fine
okay [ __ ] dead people everywhere ah
geez all right you got a key card on you
sir does it look like it all right we're
gonna have to find one well it's
probably here yet I just don't like it
very much
hahaha that's me
look at that guy that guy's fab swag
that's a thing by the way
man this game is just a [ __ ] joy to
play I'm not gonna lie it's no way I
could just be like hey you know what I'm
gonna stop no way all right here we go
hey [ __ ] hello
closing that [ __ ] exit through the
showers what the [ __ ] does that mean
okay not gonna question it just gonna do
it
whoa what the hell does happen Oh the
gay couple oh they got me
where is the showers I don't know what
the showers in darkness that is Yolo
I just
or stupid
slit his belly open
don't do it not worth it my ballet is
ugly I have like an Oprah belly
sorry Oprah did it made us hell you
thrown with the bus
let's be honest here okay
we're alive let's own America Lhasa
okay oh oh oh I take it Bam's makisu Oh
ba-dum ba-dum adieu oh it's you
whoa whoa what you gonna know ha
this is fire blue whoa okay MA oh [ __ ]
go through it what duck okay not doing
son barking ow
don't kill a man for being awesome going
back up
don't worry that oh that is not working
hey how you doing there sir
great to see ya don't rip my head off
okay you did it anyway
what was I Oh I'm Charlie what was I
supposed to do there Suzy okay press it
again I don't [ __ ] know
oh I didn't see that [ __ ] ah hi you're
too fat hey oh oh ah ah
you can fit oh you're angry now aren't
you fatty fat fat hey stupid [ __ ]
alright what is down there
okay well yellow oh job running behind
the [ __ ] genius oh god geez open the
door then gently close it
oh wait ah oh geez man I'm having the
best day of my goddamn life all right
brothers I hope you enjoyed depth so
it's sorry you might have seen parts of
it already but after this there should
be all clean clean episode
all right pres hope you enjoyed this
episode as always if you did go ahead
and leave a like it helps me out a lot
subscribe to become a bread today I'll
see you tomorrow in the next one
sound surprise love you hello girl how
you doing
economic oh yeah what's up